Now that you've got significant functionality working in
your application, this would be a good time
to add some unit tests. In the lesson
three folder, of the code that you downloaded from
Udacity's GitHub, you'll find the test folder. This
folder contains tests that are applicable up to the
end of lesson three. Basically, tests for the
profile functionality. Probably can't see, but we've got ProfileTest.java,
we've got ConferenceApiTest.java. So go ahead and copy the test folder into the
SRC source folder where you have your projects, the Conference Central. So you
can just drag and drop it. There it is. Now I just want you to go ahead
and delete the target directory in this folder. Whenever you
run your project, or you run it on Dev Server
or you deploy it to appspot, the output from the
build all goes into the target directory. And it gets,
it'll get recreated if you delete it. And sometimes the old
build and the old output files and the new output
files don't work well together. So, when in doubt, delete
the target directory. Since we're adding test, we want to make
sure we're starting with a clean slate. So I'm going to
delete it, and there it is. Looks like it's
gone, won't stay gone for long, but it's gone for
now. Okay. Now let's go to Eclipse. Going to refresh
the project, since we've added the test directory. And deleted
the target directory. Okay. So target on, target's still
there. So whenever you do delete the target directory, it
actually pretty much automatically gets recreated right away with a
couple of things in it. But it doesn't have everything
that's needed. Here down in the source directory,
you'll see the test folder now, and it has
two tests. It has ProfileTest.java in the domain
package, and it has ConferenceApiTest.java in the SPI packet.
So let's take a look at the tests.
First, I'm going to look at ProfileTest.java. Here we have
our class ProfileTest. So I'll start by defining
some values that we're going to need in our tasks.
And we do the setup, and all we're doing this set, for setup here is we create a
new profile and we supply some values. Then we
have to tear down method, which one we need. And
then here's our first test. We're testing the Getters.
Very simple. Just checking, that the values in the profile
are in fact values we put in the profile.
Then we check what happens when we update the profile.
So what we're going to do, is update the display
name and the t-shirt size. And then we want to
check that the display name is updated, and the
t-shirt size is updated. But in fact, the user ID
and the email, don't get updated. They need to
remain as they were. And then this other function here
is commented out, because it tests some functionality that you
haven't implemented yet, so the test wouldn't work. Now let's
look at ConferenceApiTest.java. So here we are,
ConferenceApiTest, and again, the first thing we do
is set up some values for testing on. Have our service helper. Do the setup.
And in this case, the main thing we're doing is creating a new user with
an email, and a user ID. We have the tearDown method. And then we stop testing.
So the first thing we do is testing getting the
profile first time. Now we test saving the profile. Now we
test saving the profile with null values and, so on. Have
a look at the different tests that we do, and then
you get to a point where it's commented out, and that's
because they're testing functionality you
haven't implemented. Like, you can't test
creating a conference, because we haven't written function to create a
conference here. And as you go through the lesson, you can
come back into ConferenceApiTest.java. And comment the testing
functions, as the functions are ready for testing.
Okay. Now we're going to look at running
the project when we've got tests. So if we
go up to Conference Central, this time I'm
going to choose Run As and then Run Configurations. And
this is my configuration to run the, run
the Dev Server on localhost. And you see here,
there is Skip Tests check box. So by default, tests
are not skipped. It hasn't mattered up until now, because we
haven't had any tests in there. So it didn't matter
whether they were skipped or not. But now, the tests will
be run. If, if at any point you find that
the tests are blocking you or you want to deploy without
the test, you can come and click this Skip Tests, but
let's not do that. Okay. So I'm going to run. Now
I'm running as per normally see the tests? Okay. My Dev Server is
running. Let me scroll back up and see what the results of the tests were. Okay.
So it run seven tests. There were
zero failures. Zero errors, zero skipped, and it
took 0.415 seconds, and then here's the
summary. Okay, good. Okay. We'll that's all fine.
But what happens if you actually do have an error? So to test that, to
test the tests. Let's introduce an error. So
since we're testing the profile functionality, I'm going
to make one of the functions to do
with profiles return an unexpected result. Okay. So
we have the getProfile method, and this gets
the profile associated with the logged in user.
And to get the profile entity out of the
datastore, we have to first create a key. And
we specify the class, which is profile.class. And then
the see it's the key, user ID. But let's
say we made a mistake, and we put the
user ID inside a string. Which is something that
does happen. Now, there's no error here. This is
a valid kind of value here, so. It doesn't
show me an error. Now let's' see what happens when we run our tests.
Now I'm going to run the project, on localhost. Okay. This time we've
got an, an error. Failed to execute, and we got an error in the test.
And we got the error in testGetProfile. No huge surprise there.
So, you see we have the stack trace. But at the bottom, we have a nice summary
where it shows the tests, the gave in error, and how many failures. And now, the
other thing I want to show you, it's over in your target directory.
May need to refresh your project here. In the target directory, you
see a folder called surefire-reports.
And this directory contains results of the report.
So if we look at ProfileTest.txt, this is not
where we had our errors. Zero failures, zero errors.
If we look at ConferenceApiTest.txt, whoo, lots of errors.
But here, failures. There was, there's actually only one
error, but this is stack trace. But now, if
we come down, I want you to look at
the, the, see what happens with the XML files.
If I click on ConferenceApiTest.xml, it'll show me
the functions that got called, and the ones
with the error, or the failures. In this
case here, it takes me straight to where
I had the error. The problem I can see right here is that, is that the user ID
did not match what was expected. So, I'm going to go ahead now actually and just
fix my code before I forget. Okay. There's my code
we'll fix. Now when I run it, I won't get
any errors. As you continue through the lesson, be sure
to add the test for the new functionality as you
implement it. In some cases, you'll need to get the
test file from the appropriate lesson folders. As you implement
new endpoint functions, you can simply uncommon the tests that
are already in Conference API Tests. And if you deviate from
the code that we have you write, like if you add
your own functions or you change what the functions do, then you're
going to need to update the tests and add your own tests
to make sure that you're testing the functionality that's in your application.